[Aplausos]
a pesar de la intensa lluvia cientos de
cariocas han salido hoy a la plaza de
zinelandia para mostrar su repulsa
contra los actos antidemocráticos que
ayer sacudieron la ciudad de Brasilia y
todo el país no es la única ciudad donde
Defensores de la Democracia quieren
hacer sentir su voz en las principales
capitales de este país tan grande Hay
personas diciendo No a la violencia
estamos aquí para demostrar que no
estamos de acuerdo con Los atentados
estamos a favor de la democracia y que
deseamos que no haya amnistía que todos
los acusados sean presos y juzgados como
se debe
a democracia la democracia en Brasil es
un proceso muy reciente
nos impidieron debutar durante más de 21
años
hoy no podemos permitir que controlen
nuestro voto nuestro poder de elegir
tenemos que Mostrar que el otro lado
existe que dice no no queremos eso
queremos respeto a los resultados
electorales queremos la garantía de las
libertades democráticas y vamos a
combatir la extrema derecha
Además hoy a lo largo de todo el día han
sido desmantelados varios campamentos de
bolsonaristas en muchas ciudades de
Brasil en Brasilia ha habido al menos
1.200 detenidos y aquí en Río de Janeiro
también se ha procedido a desmantelarlo
ha habido resistencia Y algún periodista